- And well now you have two boys
and Ryan posted this video of you guys
doing a hot sauce challenge.
- Yes.
So who was the toughest?
(children yelling)
- [Woman] We lost Amaré.
- It's Andrew and Amaré.
But who's that? Is that me?
- I don't know but
someone in the background
is living their best life.
- [Sterling] Yeah, they're going,
So that's Amaré running through,
like going dramatic with the hot sauce.
And everybody's head
was sweating profusely,
- [Kelly] Yes.
- But like I watched this one show
and you interview
and you like just eat hot
wings throughout the thing.
And I was like, I'm preparing for it.
So, and they just said like,
I want to do it with you dad.
And was like, okay.
And then Andrew, after like
wing number three, he was like,
oh, it's too much.
And Amaré like let's go.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Like let's go.
The six year, he was five at the time.
He was like, okay, I did it.
- [Kelly] He was like 'what?'
- All the way through to the end.
- Oh my gosh, so he's the toughest.
- And then you touched
his head is just wet
and slick with sweat all over,
but it was mind over matter.
- The sweat.
- The kid is strong.
- [Kelly] I love it. I love it.
Wait, so in the video, your son, Andrew
- Yeah.
- Looks at the camera
and well, let's just see it.
- [Sterling] Let's see it.
We're starting off with sauce number one.
- [Woman] Here we go.
(Andrew laughs)
- [Sterling] Shouldn't be too bad. Okay?
- 'Sup ladies?
- [Woman] Lord, help us all.
- Yeah, here we go.
- [Kelly] Ladies? What's up ladies?
- He feels good about himself.
- [Kelly] You better just
buckle up for a ride.
- You know what I'm saying?
I don't want 'em to not
feel good about himself.
So we'll just
- [Kelly] That's some
frightening foreshadowing though.
- It really, really is.
- [Kelly] I was like yeah,
That's my five-year-old by the way,
- [Sterling] Really?
- My sister or my daughter had a play date
with one of her friends,
and she's a couple of
years older than my son
and my son apparently came out to the pool
without a shirt on didn't
wear like his rash guard.
Just no top and just the shorts
- [Sterling] Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- And was like, 'ladies.'
- [Sterling] Fellin' himself.
- Five.
- [Sterling] Feelin' himself.
- He's five.
- Yeah.
- And I'm scared.
- They are who they are when
they come into the world.
You know what I'm sayin'
- [Kelly] Amen.
- But let's me know when
we're gonna have the talk,
- [Sterling] Sure.
- Yeah.
- It's already happened.
- [Kelly] Like, just get in there.
- Birds and bees, we've been
- [Kelly] You got to get in there.
- We are back with Sterling K. Brown.
(audience cheers)
His show "This is Us" is back on NBC
starting January 4th.
So let's talk, "This is Us."
Like, how are you feeling?
Is it bittersweet?
Because this is such a brilliant cast.
The chemistry is done so well. Every,
It's such a popular show
and it's just such a great message too,
the family vibe from the show,
- [Sterling] Yeah.
- which has been so great overall.
So is it kind of bittersweet for you,
are you excited to do other things,
but you're also like kind of sad.
- That's exactly what it is.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I love the show.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- It's been one of the best
six year ride of my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like professionally. It's
been absolutely amazing.
Beautiful people.
I'm looking at my black
Pearson family over here
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Sterling] and I've gotten a chance
to see these three little
girls grow up over time.
Like every time I'm on
stage with them, I'm like,
I'm gonna miss them.
And I see their parents who
were backstage with them,
and I was like, I love your daughters.
- [Kelly] And you've watched them grow up.
- And I've literally watched them grow up.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So once we start to get to like
the last two or three episodes,
there'll be something that happens
that I won't be able
to stop from happening
- Oh no.
- [Sterling] Because I know
I'm actually saying goodbye.
Right now I'm like, 'oh,
we're having a great time.'
And just blah, blah, blah.
When it gets to the end,
- [Kelly] Oh no.
- There'll be no acting.
- It'll be ugly cry.
- [Sterling] It'll be ugly.
- Okay.
- Hideous.
- [Kelly] Hideous? That's great though.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So you have a few cool projects
- [Sterling] Yep.
- coming up after "This is Us,"
so can you reveal any?
- I can reveal a few.
I got a limited series on Hulu coming up,
called "Washington Black."
It's about a young slave boy who was,
It's a 2019 best seller
on the New York Times,
young black boy named Washington Black,
growing up on a slave
plantation in Barbados.
Escapes from that plantation
with his abolitionist brother,
abolitionist slave master's
brother on a flying machine.
They crashed into a pirate ship.
They wind up going to the states.
They flee to Nova Scotia.
They have to go to the Arctic.
They come back to Europe
and then wound up ultimately in Africa.
So it's this globe trotting adventure
- [Kelly] Wow!
- That's set in the 1800s,
that I'm very excited about.
So I got that coming out.
I'm doing a buddy comedy
with Randall Park,
who's one of my favorite
funny people after like,
"You'll Always Be My Maybe,"
if you ever see that on Netflix.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Guys absolutely fantastic.
So we're going to do a little
buddy cop thing together,
which is a lot of fun.
I got to let another
action thing with Amazon
that's coming out called "Coyote Blue"
where a brown gets to kick a little butt.
I cry a lot so I'm trying
to like work other muscles
besides the tear ducts,
you know what I'm saying?
- I've more things to add.
- [Sterling] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm tryin' to segue into
some other things as well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's just a few of them that I'm,
- [Kelly] That's exciting! That's so cool!
- Thank you. Thank you very much.
- I'm excited to see you
in other things as well.
It's like really cool.
And you're an ambassador
with Survivorship Today.
So through Bristol, I
want to say this right,
Myers Squibb, right?
- Bristol Myers Squibb, correct.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So could you tell everybody
what that is about?
- I absolutely can.
So Survivorship Today is a program about
how people are living
long-term with cancer.
I got involved in this particular program
because in 2004,
my uncle, Sonny, passed away six months
from the day of his
diagnosis from cancer. Okay.
- Wow.
- Devastating thing for my family.
And so what can I do to sort
of like, you know, lift some,
bring some attention to the
cancer world and survivorship.
The good thing is people
are living longer,
but just because you're living longer,
doesn't mean your life goes
back to what it was before.
- [Kelly] The quality, yeah.
- Exactly.
So there is a series of conversations
that are available on the websites,
survivorshiptoday.com
where you can see people
who are going through
what you've gone through
and how they have survived this process.
Because one thing that the
past two years has taught me
is how important community is
and how devastating it
is when we are deprived
- Yeah and isolated. Yeah.
- Of community.
- You know what I'm saying?
So if you feeling that intense isolation
that you can by going through something
that no one else was going through,
go check it out.
Feel emboldened by the
fact that you are not alone
and for the caregivers as well.
It's incredibly informative.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
So, well we actually have a man named A.J.
in our audience.
- [Sterling] You do, right there.
- He's one of the survivors
this program works with,
he's a survivor of lung cancer.
So, hey A.J.
- [A.J.] Hi, Kelly.
- Come on, you can stand up.
(crowd cheers)
- [Sterling] My man.
- [Kelly] So can you tell us a little
of your survivorship like story?
- [A.J.] Sure, absolutely.
After two years of struggling
with going from doctor to doctor,
not knowing what's wrong with me,
just a hissing sound.
I was eventually given the devastating,
most devastating news.
I have stage four lung cancer.
Still emotional today
because I was told,
'you won't probably
see beyond six months,'
just like Uncle Sonny.
- Yeah.
- And it ripped everything out of me.
And today that was eight
and a half years ago.
I was told,
(crowd cheers)
- Thank you. Thank you.
I feel truly blessed,
but what people don't understand is,
as my daughter will tell you,
I look like a supermodel.
You know, everything is great.
But in reality,
I go through a lot of psychological
and emotional struggles on a daily basis,
just unbuttoning my shirt,
impossible, impossible.
I had to have brain surgery.
I lost function on the
right side of the body.
This arm is a beautiful arm.
Looks like a great prop on set,
but cannot do anything, it's useless.
And so I cannot even unbutton my shirt.
And so life is a struggle on a daily basis
and I'm emotionally challenged.
Every single day, I am told by
all the decoration around me,
you have cancer,
you will not survive very long.
And what survivorship
today has allowed me to do
is to realize to live in this moment,
to live in this present being that I am,
and recognizing just how
beautiful my existence is.
The beauty of everybody
that's surrounding me,
the beauty of the world.
And I live moment to moment.
And that's the beauty of this program.
For me personally,
I am so truly blessed
from six months to eight and a half years,
you think it's a miracle,
but at a bigger miracle
for me is my family.
My family had been me
behind me from day one,
picking up offerings
when I couldn't get up.
And it's so humbling to know
that a wife will stand right by you
at the time of your worst nightmare.
And my children, who were
only very little at the time,
have grown up to become future doctors
who want to make a difference
in the world of cancer
and cancer care.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- So I'm really impressed.
My oldest boy just graduated as a doctor.
- [Kelly] Wow!
(crowd cheers)
- Because it probably made an impact.
So, well, thank you so much for being here
and sharing your story.
And thank you to everybody
who's a part of it.
Like it's just such an amazing thing.